Bonjour to Lomond a Bienvenue Judy a
prima D Joseph vaudeville Brody podcast
lundi Martin Asher just checking in sir
what's up [__] bonjour je
m'appelle Guillaume I just read on
Lipari and I'm a little buzzed
I'm Michael idea I had a couple of does
just says what's on cut see we'll play
we miss you what the [__] you say
afterwards and they come back l'm m
shows Monsieur or whatever the [__] I
don't know the armies wanted not
completely shit-faced right now it's cuz
I have a kid
that's another good reason for becoming
a parent it's not because you want to
raise a good person and experience a
level of love mo that you've never felt
before it's really because you've failed
in your own attempts at sobriety and
you're too much of a loner and you're
too antisocial to ever go to a a that's
the time to have an old phone to have a
kid a baby right
we outweigh that means yeah yeah yeah
that way you said think we you sound
like some dumb tourist right yes so much
funny over here is I've been just
[__] torturing these people with my
French and I don't give a [__] when they
start speaking English back to me I
don't switch over I'm gonna [__] sit
there and search for the word and you're
gonna sit there and [__] take it like
you have the biggest [__] [__] ever
sitting across from you on the $10,000
pyramid and the clock's ticking and you
ain't went in merde
baby I [__] love it over here I love
the people I love the food I
I could literally lose the next 20 years
of my life staying over here pretending
that I'm an intellectual there's just
something about getting shit-faced in a
cafe you just don't feel like you know
we don't do it right now
America we think they make it go inside
where it's all dark and you got a hunch
down and [__] it takes you like 20
minutes just for your eyes to adjust to
see if does anybody else in there right
person you've been hitting on is it him
or her a man IRISA hit comes Pat out
yeah they think let you be a drunk in
public you just sit there on the side of
the new rule the street right and you
[__] sit there with the sport coat on
a little pocket square and you you if
you feel like you're reading I have not
improved myself at all as a human being
over here and I could not be having more
fun I have eaten a [__] baguette
every goddamn day I've gone to no
museums I went to the North Road um way
I went over there final I was just we
went over there go let's take a [__]
picture and what I love about my laughs
mall proper thumb is that she doesn't
give a [__] about that stuff either I
told you that story we went to Louvre
right and we did what everybody who
doesn't give a [__] about art does we
went in there we were like hey [__] the
other nine hundred million square feet
of art where is the Mona Lisa Mona Lisa
right and they told her it was and we
went in there we like there it is a
little bit bigger than a stamp you good
I'm good let's get the [__] out of here
and that was it that's it we left I
thought oh gosh I don't know how we get
out of there but we be I don't remember
the exact directions okay but we've just
[__] got out of there and you know
when we were coming into town which I
used to know that word I wish I could
have taken a video if I was ever
teaching a class on creativity
okay first of all who the [__] would
ever have me teach anything and secondly
where do I get off acting like I'm
creative I'm a curmudgeon and I'm good
at criticizing [__] all right
however I'm gonna criticize this there
was like [__] I think I already
talked about this we would passing in
front of
the Louvre and there's that stupid
[__] glass pyramid that they made
that I think a lot of Parisians didn't
like you know they don't like anything
new anything new is [__] you know I
don't know I don't know what they call
it
vulgar that's one of the best insults
ever you know to describe something you
just did and unless someone just said a
bunch of Ethel I'm senate's it's
whatever but if you'd like Bridget to
make fun of somebody's shirt the design
of it and described it as vulgar I don't
know it's about as deep as it gets for
someone who doesn't curse I think right
someone was a sport coat onstage right
standing up there like Johnny Carson
still hosting the Tonight Show and
they're working on their five minutes
that I don't [__] know anyways we
were driving through you cut through and
a lot is a bunch of [__] tourists all
standing up having somebody else take
their picture as they pretend to be like
holding the top of the pyramid I swear
to god we drove by and there was like
nine people all doing it at the same
time you know and if I was ever liberal
essa' I would take a video of that and
you go you see this [__] right here if
you want to be create don't do that
there's a difference between being
inspired by seeing somebody doing
something and then just going up and
doing exactly what the [__] they're
doing yeah it's still gonna be a great
picture but what's gonna happen is
that's gonna be the [__] hacky thing
that you do right until somebody
switches it up and this is what kills me
there's gonna be one person that
switches up what you do with yourself in
the foreground of that stupid [__]
glass pyramid in front of that you right
and if it gets enough hits and lol's and
oh my god this is the greatest Instagram
photo ever then everybody will do that
you know I don't know someone will plank
on it if people spin but that [__]
moment of creativity laying face down on
something I'm not laying face down and
not doing anything I'm play
oh Jesus bill couple of beers and you
become even more [__] ear huh why don't
you order a side order a tampons um
anyways I resent the fact that I have to
still do these [__] things alright
I'm on vacation do you go to work when
you're on vacation I don't think you do
my relatives came out to that show when
I was in England and they bought me a
bottle I don't know why but they have
salted caramel oh my god
Coco vodka liqueur and it's just been
sitting here staring at me and I gotta
be honest with you I'm just wondering I
gotta know what that hangover feels like
it's like you ever watch one of those as
far as hangovers go you ever watch
sounds like it's almost nap time yeah
here you ever watch one of those things
on like what the Army Ranger training or
naval Navy SEAL training yeah this is
like the Hank like you think you had a
[__] hangover like you think you're
out there right you think you're working
out doing your little CrossFit [__] and
running up down the street while I sit
there in a [__] cafe getting hammered
wearing my little sport coat you know
like you're [__] showing me up like
I'm impressed with you and you think
you're a badass
then you watch that [__] you watch what
[__] army ranges and all those
special force people right I mean just
next-level [__] P the people that
Matt Damon plays in a movie you don't I
mean not the people that get applause as
they trudge through the airport in their
fatigues to go sit into a cubicle to
order grenades that they're never gonna
throw these are the [__] people that
a list movie stars play right well this
bottle here this is like I don't know if
this is the [__] and this hangover right
you know that when they lift up that
[__] log those army ranges and
there's like [__] 20 of them and then
when somebody [__] falls over in
pukes and they got to pick up their own
puke and take it outside the zone and
then they're out and now there's 19 here
and then you got to hold up his wake
whatever that [__] metaphor is
oh my god you know fast that would be
out of that pit yeah we just like dude I
need my back for the rest of my life
okay and I don't need the pressure of
everybody else's defendant on me and I'm
the weak link in the chain I understand
I'm barely surviving standing out here
and the [__] Sun forget about going
over there and picking up a [__]
telephone pole with [__] nine other
people who have the genetics of a
[__] pit bull okay I don't I'm a lap
dog okay I'm the kind of dog that could
go on a plane before they had that
[__] where you could say oh this
thing is like helping me emotionally I
don't know I didn't want to talk about
does that fill up enough time [__] nine
minutes this is like when I'm bombing on
stage
oh my god I just gotta end this set I
got to do a half hour it's got to be
like 28 minutes right nine minutes I'm
not a [__] material um so anyways we
are staying in the whatever I might say
what the [__] yeah there'll be some
weirdo somehow will find me then I gotta
[__] sit there and answer questions
about how to start a podcast in Paris
excuse moi mr. Gilbert how you say um
only busy Ellis D um anyways plowing
ahead so my condolence to my fellow
Americans right now if you're not into
baseball cuz that's the only game in
town baby and don't even talk to me
about the W and NB NB a I know it's much
better the level of play is much better
I understand that okay but that's like
you know it's very rare UFC did it UFC
UFC did it and they went not only did
they start after the big four big three
really and then hockey comes along but
when you wait you wait until they add
Seattle you wait to the add Seattle and
all those [__] rain-drenched
Lumberjacks okay who are tired of all of
those [__] ridiculous Harry [__]
muffs up there have another thing that
they can focus their attention on you
wait till the NHL is going to start
nipping at the heels of I'm gonna say
baseball
I'm gonna go with baseball all right
they built a bunch of new stadiums the
steroid error is over and it just sort
of settling into like this is what we do
you know if I were the owners in the MLB
right now I would say all right we need
some sort of synthetic [__] steroid
all right we'll do it just like the
pharmaceutical companies did with heroin
okay we'll make a synthetic version of
steroids and we'll just sorta leak it
into I don't know sunflower seeds and
then all of a sudden all the [__]
numbers are gonna start going up right I
mean didn't you like wrestling better
when everyone was on roids I mean if
they just would just let him work a
five-day workweek you know not work them
into the ground where they [__] die I
mean roids are great aren't they at this
point don't they have them like it like
the you know like weed you can have like
the what do they call that thing there
the little mister there you know little
weed aroma thing you can buy [__] do you
call that thing breathalyzer not a
breathalyzer that's for drinking and
driving bill you should see what the
[__] breathalyzer looked like when I
took it at the police station when I got
busted for drinking driving almost 30
[__] years ago
it look like a [__] like a bagpipe in
a mix with a douche bag giant rubber
[__] hose blow into it and we're just
puffing up my cheeks try not to blow
into it cuz I knew I knew I had a big
number I knew I had a number that even
if I had F Lee [__] Bailey I wasn't
getting out of it you know might have to
have a last name like Bush Kennedy one
of those [__] royalty names one of
those regal [__] names that everybody
in England refuses to recognize that not
only are they on par with the royal
family I would dare say that they're a
little bit beyond we're taking callers
by the way I want to thank the country
of Ireland all right for coming up with
a [__] jumpers all right this thing
has been the [__] late night in Paris
walking around smoking a cigar you know
with my stupid [__] Brian Johnson
ac/dc had on
I really look like the old man that I am
and I'm enjoying it you know god I was
thinking this morning laying in bed not
being able to sleep I was thinking back
to some [__] when I was a kid and I was
thinking like oh my god that's like 45
[__] years ago forty five years ago
was 1973 now in 1973 if I ran into a
fifty year old guy and he said I was
here 45 years ago what year would that
be everybody that would be 1928
according to my couple of beers math
that's how [__] old I am now like to
a five-year-old kid right now 1973 was
what 1928 was to make when I was five
years old not that I really contemplated
I used to think the 1950s were the olden
days that's what really [__] kills me
when I was five years old SEC I could
still could have saw an Elvis I think he
wasn't even fat yet you know could have
gone into Vegas and watched him treat
watch him sing that song for the 9000
time that [__] week out in Vegas you
know I think the mob killed him I really
do
he probably signs the carnal probably
signed him to some lifetime contract and
then when he just got all fat eating
those peanut butter [__] banana
sandwiches they are just like I we gotta
get rid of this guy there's no what
happens in the mob does anybody like die
of old age I know you can die of a heart
attack sitting around eating all that
[__] you know was it linguine that's
that's the one that's bad for you right
it's like a [__] butter based cream
sauce Jesus Christ just sitting there
slurping it up having to look at the
door every two seconds so nobody comes
in and whacks you I've never understood
it beyond the cars and the pinkie rings
in the great suits and the [__]
hottest women in the [__] town you
know if you can't sit down and eat a
bowl of pasta without staring at the
[__] door every two seconds is it
really [__] worth it
maybe it is I don't know you know at
some point I should start taking college
rather than just asking [__]
questions that float out into the
[__] abyss 15 minutes that's it
Jesus I feel like I'm in [__] math
class back in back in high school oh my
god
sine cosine tangent just [__] flunk
me is that so hard do we really have to
go through 180 days of this [__]
can't you tell right from the beginning
you don't do when he's scouting they
didn't it was public schools and you
know what it was all free it's all free
but not now not now cuz every [__]
kid out there needs a goddamn tablet and
fifteen thousand other [__] things
okay and public schools can't afford to
do that anymore now can they oh they
could they could if we weren't fighting
[__] 3,500 [__] jerk-offs without
uniforms that train on a [__] jungle
gym acting like that somehow gonna
overthrow this country huh despite the
fact we've done battle with first world
nations and beat their asses do you
understand that this is a team it's not
even in the [__] league this is a
friendly was sitting there acted like
this is going to go up against their
[__] record unbelievable and
meanwhile these poor [__] kids in
America going to school right now and
we're not even decent enough with their
own tax money to provide them tablets
that they can go on to to ignore this
assignments and watch when watch free
online point that's why I'm actually
thinking about sending my kid to public
schools because they can't afford any of
that [__] right
and then maybe my kid can can go you
know actually have a childhood before
you know some other [__] degenerate
kid comes up and shows them god knows
[__] what on their phone or their
tablet and all of that [__] you know
what I mean I know I've talked about
this [__] before I know that I've said
already on this podcast that I've talked
about this [__] before I don't care if
this is like I'm going down memory
[__] lane alright this is my my
thinks in my first podcast a fish
like past the hangover of turning 50 I'm
in my I am in my 50s and let me tell you
something when you get in your fifties
you think it knows [__] what are you
talking about you [__] little
whippersnapper okay I've been around the
block for half a [__] century you
know many times I've been around the Sun
um without even noticing somebody
actually sent me that as a birthday
thing congratulations for like you had
ten thousandth trip around the [__]
Sun or something like that I think was
like ten thousand right so now how many
times you go around the Sun 50 years I
hope that's I hope I weigh over
exaggerate just just for that person
that knows the answer so they can feel
better about themselves
you like staring at a pterodactyl oh
really and why don't you go [__] spew
that out in a bar and see if you get any
[__] [__] out of it Oh
bill is that what it's all about all
right I'm not gonna look that up how
long does it take for the earth oh wait
once a year goes around the Sun once a
year doesn't it I think I remember that
I think I got that right on a science
test all right here we go how long does
it take for the earth to go around the
Sun I know this [__] thing right it
takes 24 hours for the thing to spin
around and it takes a year for it to go
around it's official they won't even
answer me that's how dumb this question
was it immediately goes to this vision
visible is visualization shows how fast
you're spinning around Earth's axis I
don't care if I can't feel it why do I
want to know it I don't give a [__]
[__] earth spinning on its axis is
like eating iceberg lettuce with nothing
on it you don't I mean how does that
taste
ah like I don't know nothing how the
earth moves this is how dumb this quite
the answers not even here oh and somehow
Joe Rogan's all this this is the thing
that nobody really considers you know as
much about I don't you wanna read that
the [__] state I'm in right now
Joe Rogan yeah Joe Rogan reads people
okay
that's the podcast you're looking for I
suggest you go to the Joe Rogan
experience I think the earth goes around
the Sun once a year I'm gonna say once a
year I feel like that last family member
on family feud you know everybody can
somehow scrape together for smart
brothers sisters and maybe a random
cousin when you go you try to get that
fifth person you know they that's if the
drop off is tremendous okay so what do
you do you always stick him there the
last [__] one and they'll just knee
and they named us a type-a dog you know
and I'd be like [__] uh a German
Shepherd German Shepherd number one you
guys want to play yet and then they go
to the next person you know and they
[__] throw out a Dalmatian and at the
day of the day to get all we gonna let a
fifth guy name a type of dog just [__]
it I can't even think of a dumb answer
for type of dog that's too easy how many
times the earth go around the Sun how
long does it take the earth go around
the Sun Bill how long do you think it
takes for the earth to go around the Sun
if you get this you guys be playing for
all the money if not the Drinkwater
family has a chance to steal what do you
say bill could you could you repeat the
question uh yeah no I can't [__] said
it four times pluck all right how long
does it take for the earth just spin
around the Sun um Richard please don't
kiss me I'm gonna say a year and a half
right which is the dumbest [__] at
least you know you know it's a solid
[__] year you know it's a round
number you're not gonna say [__] it
18 months right and then but then all
your other four family members as
they're staring daggers at you have to
[__] stand there and start clapping
and say good answer good answer good
answer and in the 40 [__] years that
that show has been on nobody has ever
just stared at another family member and
be like what the what the [__]
did you just say Oh looked at a number
family another family over and said I I
told you we shouldn't have brought this
[__] that has never happened well
you know why bill because it's a game
show when people are having fun
something you don't know how to do
alright hey you know I never I never
liked pre what do you call it promote a
podcast coming up but I got a podcast
coming up on June 28th the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast and my guests will be
none other than the one and only Dave
Ilic one of the great drummers in the
world and also my drum teacher and he
has a new drum instructional website
awesome [__] all of the [__] that
he's been showing me and everybody else
everyone from my level all the way up to
some of the best drummers in the world
and he's going hard on this thing and
he's gonna show you guys all the [__]
that he showed me so he's gonna be
coming on promoting that talking drums
and all that type of stuff just giving
you guys a heads up because I think his
I think that whole educational thing is
going to be [__] insane because I know
from firsthand experience working with
that guy over the last couple years it
is it has been a monumental shift in my
playing and I'm just some [__]
comedian that likes playing drums having
said that having said that the amount of
[__] people that showed me that that
eight-year-old asian girl playing good
times bad times and absolutely
destroying that's when I'm like my
favorite videos of all time despite the
fact I've been trying to play that song
for 30 years just the way she attacks
the kid the whole thing total rock star
comes out of the field hits the crash
she's coming out of the chair not only
did she crush it not only did she hit
the drums like a [__] monster
she was unbelievably entertaining and it
was kids like that they didn't have kids
like that when I was a kid that's like
some [__]
YouTube [__] and the whole world showing
you how to do stuff I don't know what
or maybe that's just a prodigy but that
but it was cuz of kids you know gifted
kids like that why I shifted away from
drums and ended up being a comedian
because I would go into the you know not
every time but it felt like almost every
time I would go into the local music
store you know before [__] Guitar
Center was just the one everybody went
to I used to go to a place Norfolk
Connie music County music on route 1 and
Dedham I believe is where I bought my
drum kit way back in the day back then
when the child world was down there you
know what I mean I forget what else was
down there before Toys R Us [__] took
over everything there was child world
you went by leech mears
and [__] dead I'm all of that area
right over there and a great Chinese
restaurant the movie theater all of that
[__] that I remember as a kid that's now
[__] long gone I assumed I would go
in there and they would always just be
some kid would pick up something a
guitar a [__] xylophone a goddamn
triangle and would not be just sitting
down going duh duh duh you know saying
something somebody else said they've
come in there and they would just start
[__] playing and you could tell that
it was coming from them that or if they
played something they would then add you
know that you'd heard on the radio they
then adds something their own little
thing to it and they just had ideas and
they were creative and all that and I
was musically I was those people outside
the [__] lelou and standing there you
know putting my finger on top of the
goddamn whatever the [__] you call it
the pyramid well that was depressing
Jesus bill way to bum yourself up maybe
that's some of that vodka du Chocolat I
apologize my growling stomach by the way
that's what happens when you're in a
liquid diet and then I'm going to come
back to the states here in about a week
or so and I'll be right back on the
wagon see that's what I can do I can
drink like an alcohol
and then just step off the [__] wagon
the bus whatever you call it the party
wagon and just start walking down the
street like nothing happened like a
[__] hitman right like berry like
Bill Hader and Barry just [__] walk
away like nothing happened anyway so let
me read some of the advertising here for
this week all right
I have this opening note the mushroom
coffee dude asked that you don't say it
tastes like mushrooms
other than that say anything thanks well
that's [__] easy all right
what would think mushroom coffee doesn't
taste like mushrooms I like mushrooms
all right I actually had a [__] cape
today is every day crepe crepe whatever
the [__] it is avec jumbo a fromage way
I'm sorry I apologized anybody remotely
French all right quit sorry the truth is
most of us are brushing our teeth wrong
don't wanna do it [__] stabbing
yourself in the eye not not for long
enough and forget to change our brush on
time that's because most brands focus on
selling flashy gimmicks rather than
better brushing but not quit not these
[__] guys so what makes quip so
different you may not have asked well
for starters quip is an electric
toothbrush that's a fraction of the cost
of a bulk of bulkier brushes while still
packing just the right amount of
vibrations to help clean your teeth your
teeth ladies your teeth keep the
vibration above your neck there equips
built-in timer helps you clean for the
dentist recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that remind you when it's
time to switch sides you don't even have
to think anymore
next quip subscription plans are for
your health not just convenience they
deliver new brush heads on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars including free
shipping worldwide on a dentist's Rekha
Mendon schedule that they paid the
dentist probably to say sooner than you
needed so they could sell more brush
heads and that's how the world works and
goddamn it quipped god bless you for
[__] playing the game clip also comes
with a mount that suctions right to your
mirror and unsticks when you break up
with that chick to use as a cover for a
hygienic travel wherever you take your
teeth and finally everyone loves quip
everybody does everybody loves it they
were on Oprah's ol list
Oprah's all this oh I need to paint my
mansion
yeah I'll [__] say you got a good
toothbrush named one of times best
interval inventions sorry not an
intervention and it's the first
subscription electric toothbrush
accepted by the American Dental
Association I got to tell you guys you
know why I love it an electric
toothbrush okay and this is some serious
[__] is I used to use the handheld once
I was like [__] electric toothbrushes
those things of [__] and I ended up
brushing my gum away along my [__]
tooth line ended up havin you know a
borderline gingivitis type of situation
not that what do they call it when your
receding gum whatever the [__] you call
it but what's great about these electric
toothbrushes if you don't have to move
back and forth you just put it on there
it does all the goddamn work I stand by
this despite all the negative [__] I
said I stand by this product plus
they're backed by a network of over
20,000 dentists and hygienists and
hundreds of thousands of happy brushes
who use quip every day quipped oh I hope
they do animals quip starts at just 25
dollars and if you go to get quip
dot-com slash bar right now
you'll get your first refill pack for
free with quip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack for free
at get quip calm g-e-t q UIP
[__] stomach calm / / spelled I just
did that I just felt it out all right
for sig Matic mushroom coffee man for
sig Matic comes from Finland so you know
it's good the the Finns defeated [__]
the Russians in World War two you think
they can't make it a cup of coffee
the same crunchy that gave us Santa
Claus Angry Birds
Tuukka Rask the goaltender for the
Boston Bruins and mushroom coffee finish
people consume more coffee per capita
per capita than any other country almost
three times more than Americans outright
you know got to get all competitive
during World War two when there was a
shortage of coffins to finish boiled
mushrooms that grow on trees to make
coffee mushroom coffee has half the
caffeine of regular coffee but as twice
as magical I don't know why I want to
drink this stuff so bad
easy on the gut less acidic and you
don't get the jittery feeling you get
from regular coffee it is a very smooth
earthy flavor with some sweet notes in
there for people who drink their coffee
black called adaptogenic what about for
people who like their women black well I
enjoy the coffee a little more it gives
you extra energy without more caffeine
or sugar perfect for creativity hey man
let's start a band helps when you need
to get work done think of it as
supercharged instant coffee that sounds
like some weed people talk about comes
and easy to use and carry single-serving
packets just add water perfect for
travel and when you when you're on the
go
costs just a dollar fifty per cup get
15% off your first purchase with code
bur how much money would that be
everybody it would be 15 cents in the
dollar seven and a half on the $0.50 I
would say that's twenty two and a half
cents not a [__] do you do that just go
to four sig Matic coffee calm and try it
for yourself alright lastly but not
leastly LegalZoom it's time for a
mid-year check-in if you like everyone
else you have a few things left on your
to-do list for 2018 and that's why Legal
Zoom is extending their friends and
family discount to everyone right now
that means for a limited time you get
10% of the things you keep putting off
if you're a small business owner make
your accountant happy by saving on your
LLC d/b/a S corp and more you can also
save money wrapping up
last will or a living trust before you
go on sum up vacation legal zooms not a
law firm but don't worry if legal
questions are holding you up their
network of independent attorneys can
provide advice for your business and
your estate plans and more accomplish
the things you need to get done at
legalzoom.com now and save 10% with
legal zooms friends and family discount
just be sure who am i doing right now
done it then and then oh what the hell
felt what some talking head just be sure
to enter promo code where and your
referral box at checkout
oh that's gonna drive me nuts this offer
is only available for a limited time so
hurry to legalzoom.com
right now and use promo code bar for 10%
off Legal Zoom where life meets legal
legalzoom.com who the [__] was I just
imitating anything yeah yeah one of
those talk talking head [__] people
and one of those mindless I was one of
those mindless [__] YouTube shows if
I forget what that show was called I
have no idea anyways people I think
that's I think I did it I think I did 34
minutes all right we're gonna do
something interesting here last week I
went to the finals of Roland Garros
Aaron
paddy and for those of you who didn't
get to watch it for those of you have
never been there alive I would like to
close this Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
with the sounds of the French Open as
done by Monsieur Guillaume bear all
right this is this is a point all right
and this is this is the two guys they're
I forget who so at this point all right
here we go this is what it sounded like
serve to point all right that one that
miss was the drop shot that [__] up
the other guy all right I'll see you
that's
as the Thursday afternoon go [__]
yourself have a great weekend you [__]
enjoy the music and we got another
half-hour of this type of [__] from
one that I did I don't know while ago
[Music]
just wanna make
I just wanna make
baby
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill Bert's the
Monday morning podcast from Monday June
14 2010 how the hell are you are you
good did you have a good weekend did you
did you go down to that place with the
thing I heard it was nice was it nice it
is nice oh that's nice
my son he had a recital this weekend and
we were so nervous he was all a
flustered and more suburban talk about
[__] that nobody cares about course
Frank was in the back with the garden
hose it froze up over the winner so we
have to buy a new one of those so you
know Frank course he goes on the
internet and he just starts researching
all about those holes hoses I don't can
you imagine just Lee is sitting there at
the end of a cul-de-sac like that is
your [__] reality rather than having
a wine cellar I would have just have a
secret room of [__] porn with Kleenex
for me either rub one out or just sit
there crying at what what became of my
life honey can you go out and fix his
bicycle no why doesn't he go climb a
[__] tree
Jesus Christ what did they do in the
eighteen hundreds you wonder why the
environments so [__] up that's it
right there everybody you just don't
want to go out and be a part of your
kids lives I don't that's why I told you
I enjoyed condoms I didn't enjoy condoms
I just didn't want to bust one in you
without one on and now I did and now
look at it look at my face sweetheart
can't you see the misery fuck'em well he
half looks like you you go fix his
[__] bike I'm not yelling I'm no I'm
not all right so this is the this is the
podcast for this week I got to admit
this is like the 15th time I've tried to
start it I don't know what's going on
I'm in my bedroom it's [__] hot out
because the Sun shines on this part of
my apartment during this time of the day
which is why usually I do this in the
morning cuz it's nice and cool and then
the podcast is cool as opposed to now
where it's stressed and a little sweaty
you know speaking of sweat and you guys
been watching the NBA Finals have you
been watching that [__] this series I
can't call it Lakers won the first game
as I got Jesus Christ it look
unbelievable then the Celtics come back
and I still wasn't believing in them and
I was like you know what
whoever wins Game three they're gonna
win the series that's that's the pivotal
[__] game and then the Lakers win and
I'm like ah [__] we're done we're done
and the Celtics win the next game too -
yeah but what the [__] you know Lakers
will win the next one cuz that's how
it's going and then BAM the Celtics win
again so they're up three two now logic
would say well all you gonna do is win
one out of two of their evenly matched
they're gonna [__] do it but there's
nothing logical about this series it's
been it's been a war and I hope you guys
have been watching because it has been a
classic and people stepping up
not too many bonehead mistakes although
Laker fans might say a thing or two
about Ron Artest you know I could pick
at some of my [__] players but you
know it's been a classic goddamn series
and usually usually I trash the other
team but I got nothing but respect for
the Lakers I got nothing mr. [__]
great team and I don't know what's gonna
happen I don't
we're gonna close it out the next game
will we win seven games will the Lakers
win the next two I don't [__] know
but I don't understand why they can't
play a game on Saturday night when does
the NBA afraid of you know we have
TiVo's I don't I already [__] examine
this [__] I was just glad we swatted Pau
Gasol a couple of times last night you
know gave him a nice cold bucket of
water to remind him of what a [__]
[__] we think he is now he's been
playing great the whole goddamn series
and Kobe is is that guys he is unfuckin
garda both guys unguardable that third
quarter he had Game five last night was
unbelievable you see that [__]
three-pointer was he like 15 feet behind
the line and it what it killed me is he
threw it like it looked like a Shaq foul
shot except it went in it was like a
frozen rope it was like barely any arc
on the ball and there was still nothing
but net it's like he'd [__] defies
the laws of physics and there's a lot of
people out there as my voice cracks a
little bit because I've been screaming
for seven successful shows at Caroline's
this weekend
I [__] raped the crowd this weekend I
was in his own baby is having a great
[__] time out that way but let's
stick with the Lakers people keep
[__] comparing saying you know he's
the next Jordan he isn't this is how you
know somebody isn't the next Jordan is
there compared to Michael Jordan they
say he's the next Jordan all right so
that all that means is that you're
playing at this is is he playing at the
same level as Michael yes he is well
doing if you change planning same
[__] levels Michael Jordan
then are we tell you Michael Jordan I'll
tell you why
this is the [__] difference Michael
Jordan changed the [__] game and I
keep telling you sports constants and
you don't [__] listen to me it's like
you don't hear me you don't understand
all right
it's like what do ice it's like [__]
Christopher Columbus before that guy
came along everybody thought the world
was flat then if you sailed too far
you'd go right off the edge of it but
Columbus realized that it was round and
there was people to be massacred on the
other side of the [__] globe
he realized that
and he became the first [__] guy to
go over whether they didn't think well
maybe come some people say the Vikings
but whatever let's just go with him get
in the [__] credit alright just so I
can make my example work here now after
he [__] does it if another guy comes
along and he does it too he sailed at
the level of Columbus but he didn't do
some groundbreaking [__] which is what
Jordan did Jordan changed the [__]
game Kobe is just playing the game at
the same level as as a Michael Jordan
he's playing the game but he's not doing
[__] that I know that I haven't seen
Michael already do you know so there you
go that's what I'm saying
the same way dr. J changed basketball
before dr. J came in the [__] league
everybody in the league looked like
basically half the league look like they
they had my ability to play you know and
then all of a sudden he comes along and
the game gets elevated above the [__]
rim and he's doing [__] in the ABA that
nobody even thought about doing
all right and then everybody sees him do
it and it's like oh that's [__]
possible and then they practice his
[__] moves and now they're doing it
and it becomes a part of the [__]
game that's the difference right and
before [__] Jordan came along
everyone's like you got to have a center
you can't win without a big man and
Jordan was the first guy to come along
and says you know what [__] your big man
and [__] your power forward and [__] the
fact that I don't even have a goddamn
Center and we did have a center but the
guy sucked luc longley or Cartwright
he's like [__] it uh you know what I
don't need any of them I'm gonna jump
over all of them and [__] throw it
down that's what I'm doing
took it to the next level nobody dunked
the way he [__] dunked until he did
it all that [__] you know what I'm
saying
so stop with this [__] all right but I
will tell you this without a doubt I
think he's the most unbelievable [__]
player that I've seen since Jordan but
there's still a major gap do you know
what I mean
guys understand what I'm trying to say
here it's like Miles Davis changed
[__] music okay you buddy Billy down
the street he plays the trumpet there's
a difference he's good at playing it I'm
not saying he's not good at playing it
I'm not saying he can't play the songs
that Miles Davis made but he's not
[__] Miles Davis who the [__] goes
from sports to Miles Davis is it any
wonder this podcast is free do you know
my web guy told me other day I have over
250,000 downloads of my podcast not a
week I don't know exactly how much time
or how many people maybe that's what
that's from 14 listeners downloading it
58 [__] times each does that come out
to 250,000 I don't know what it does but
I was impressed and I was just thinking
you know what what if I actually sold it
for a buck a whack there'd be 250 grand
right government comes in
they knock it down to a buck 25 right oh
maybe I can't get to keep a buck 40 of
it but I got a [__] throw it on the
crap table that is Wall Street then they
[__] come along
they shake up the economy like an ant
farm now I'm down to 30 grand right
there I still got 30 grand I can go out
and go buy another Prius see how that
works that's how America works speaking
of that [__] I was on the plane
yesterday okay and this [__] dude
comes on you know with with what I
described as game 7bo one of these dudes
where he walks down he doesn't smell and
then the second he goes to put his
luggage into the overhead compartment
it's just like you have got to be
[__] kidding me
how did this guy make it through
security you know I can't bring water
through security but he can bring this
this [__] stench onto the plane of
course he [__] sits right behind me
you know and I'm just like please just
keep your [__] arms down fortunately
he did but it's those guys always get on
on the cross-country [__] flights so
anyways there was this adorable woman
next to me and she was from Australia
had the little [__] accent and all
that type of [__] so what have a long
story short we're taking off from JFK
and one of the runways is shut down so
it's taken four [__] ever write a
couple people on the plane are in
wheelchairs so that takes more time you
know you proverbial fat [__] you know
the whole deal so we take off like an
hour and a half late that's just the
whole [__] it then the bedtime we land
we land there's no gate and then we got
to sit there and wait to get towed in
and the whole thing's taken forever and
she does this [__] where she just goes
she says she goes is everything in
America slow you know so I let it slide
and then the plane
we're all trying to see who won the
Celtics of the Lakers cuz we all missed
the [__] game thank God ESPN showed
the replay I caught the second half and
it goes around the plane like wildfire
fire you know the Celtics won Celtics
won and this girl Maya Moreau was joking
about how much people give this [__] and
then this girl Miss comics something
well you know Americans [__] blah
blah blah blah and it's just like you
know what
I let it slide with the first [__]
one but it's just really enough like
they always talk about the ignorant
American what kind of a [__] [__]
comes here from another country and
shits on the country to somebody who's
from this country
when I was over in England I didn't walk
around saying to English people how
[__] awful their torsos were I didn't
do that
they said I enjoyed England I'm like
it's [__] great I can't believe I'm
over here
Royal Albert Hall it's beautiful I can't
wait to come over here again phenomenal
[__] City I didn't say your food
sucks you guys all have Will Ferrell
mushy torsos I didn't say any of that
[__] I didn't talk about your teeth
being [__] up I didn't talk about the
weird inbred look because you've all
been [__] each other and the same
goddamn strip of land for [__]
thousands of years I didn't do that [__]
I was on my best behavior and Here I am
sitting x2 this [__] clam who is
everything in America slow as opposed to
what that beacon of speed that [__]
Australia is [__] people you know I
went to Australia I was there for like
three days I had a good time down there
but you know I could have picked that
place apart all the unemployed people
just sitting in bars drinking [__]
you know same [__] [__] same goddamn
just [__] that's all it is everybody
taking pot shots in America now that's
what it is because we've been on top and
we've been exploiting their labor and I
guess maybe that's maybe we deserve a
little bit of that [__] but you know
what take a look in the [__] mirror
Australia or a woman from Australia the
[__] I went there was this like wow like
I was going into the future can I have a
ham and then the [__] sandwiches
right my hand before I even finish it I
didn't find them to be overly fast over
there either
you wait you [__] wait you think it's
not coming your way our corporations are
just ahead of the curve of where where
your corporations are our corporations
have basically exploited every last
legal way that they can make more
[__] money over here so now they're
just stealing they're just stealing and
they're cutting [__] staff members I
actually had to wait like a half-hour 40
minutes to get my bag last night I think
it was that Sunday thing once again it's
Sunday it's Sunday so we just have like
a skeleton crew
I don't know all I'm saying you know
it's just bugging me it's like do you
think I know that
that [__] isn't a little [__] up over
here do I need you to come over here I
would never be in Australia and go like
yeah Australians to another [__]
Australian you know that's the type of
[__] I felt like [__] stuffing her in
a goddamn boogie board bag boogie board
bag why don't I pick that because I saw
that documentary of that stupid [__]
from Australia who put 200 pounds of
[__] weed into a boogie board bag all
right
alliteration for you and then goes to
like Bali you know if you even have cold
medication they hang you by your balls
in the public square and she gets life
imprisonment well that's what you get
you dumb [__] that's what you get that's
one of my thing out [__] Australia
that's how it were you see and that's
how it works right there there's a lot
of people in Australia right now maybe
listen to this [__] going you know I
would never say that I would never do
that if I went yeah well one of you did
so there you go do you think Germany
likes to be judged by Hitler alone they
don't I bet there's a lot of sweethearts
over in Germany look at all those
[__] fat jolly people during
Oktoberfest running around dressed like
they're in Hansel and Gretel you know
[__] on each other or whatever weird
fetishes they're into over there all
right what Anna just [__] bugs me
anyway so it was my it was my birthday
this weekend I had a wonderful birthday
I did to Stu uh sold out shows that's
life the first show was sold out the
second one was like 90% sold out on a
Thursday by the way and afterwards I had
I had a slice of cake and a shot a
whiskey and then another shot of whiskey
and I'll tell you right now if you want
a [__] hangover have a slice of
birthday cake with a little bit of
maker's and you're gonna be in business
I was wrong because I really [__]
abused my body this weekend I really did
and I blame you know I blame I blamed
Joe DeRosa I just blame him there's just
something about him you know comes down
he's got that stupid look on his face he
already has a drink in his [__] hand
and you know I don't want a drink with
him but it's like I know he's I know he
was adopted it's like what am I gonna be
yet another person who rejects this poor
bastard that's the only reason why I
drink hang on a second I got to turn the
fan of this [__] alright how far are
we into it sixteen pathetic minutes into
this podcast this has really been a
lackluster podcast and I want to
apologize I got to tell you something
guys I've started this thing like
[__] six times already and I don't
know I'm just I'm off this week
look at me I'm tackin I'm attacking my
good friend Joe DeRosa you know it's a
good friend of mine
love the guy respect him
even though when he sits down he looks I
look at him and he looks like he has
wheelchair legs next time if you guys
ever go out and you see Joe DeRosa
sitting at the back of a club just when
he sits down tell me it looks like his
legs work you know every time he stands
up you get like that excitement like
you're you've seen a miracle happening
no let me see what I'm doing him I'm
attacking Joe he's not even here to
defend himself
oh geez there bill what are you doing um
it was my birthday this weekend and I
got a lot of birthday well wishes on my
birthday I want to thank everybody and
then I also got a lot of a happy belated
birthday and I I really don't I don't
enjoy that all right if you didn't
remember then [__] man up and just
say yeah hey I forgot your birthday
sorry about that you know I was busy in
my own life or you know maybe I don't
give a [__] about you enough to remember
it just say that say happy belated
birthday I don't like that that's like
merry xmas taking all the fun out of it
all right if you forgot my birthday do
you think I actually remember that you
didn't that she didn't [__] say happy
birthday to me
I was totally fine with whoever said
happy birthday to me on my birthday and
then then you you gotta come the next
[__] day you know I'm still smiling I
still got frosting on the side of my
mouth I'm having a great goddamn time
and you got to come up to me and wish me
a happy belated birthday to remind me
that you didn't give a [__] enough to
[__] wish me happy birthday right
before you said that I didn't know I
didn't know that you didn't wish me
happy birthday nor did I give a [__] I
actually looked up a lady cuz I didn't
know what it meant I know what belated
birthday means you missed my birthday
sorry about that but belated is one of
those those weird words in the English
language that is used but it's only used
then
do you ever hear belated at any other
point during the year Jesus Christ look
at that [__] belated pizza son of a
[__] you don't this is like a bad 80s
bit ones ooh the word belated belated
actually means later in relation to the
proper time something should have
happened so like when I finally get get
like married can that connect with will
I have a belated wedding
you know if a woman carries a baby for
[__] 10 months
do they have belated giving birth cards
Jesus I really should be wearing a
[__] 80 sports coat right now with
the sleeves pulled up one of those Miami
Vice t-shirts underneath it spiking up
what's left of my hair you know coming
up onstage to like some sort of ripoff
of the Top Gun theme benedict dank dan
laughs good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the funny bone um I wish
I did stand up in the eighties it just
seems so much easier and you could like
literally do coke and go on stage and
nobody had a [__] problem with it
could be absolutely out of your [__]
mind and it was considered okay because
it was the 80s
we I tell you what why don't we just
actually jump to the some of these
segments that I have here let's let's
recommend some YouTube videos for the
week okay and why don't we just settle
in that this isn't gonna be one of the
good podcasts okay why don't we just
take the pressure off me and just
realize that this isn't gonna be one of
the good ones you know look at the Coen
brothers every one of their movies good
are they I don't [__] know I just had
to pick somebody really successful I bet
they made a bad one so whatever this is
my [__] bad one uh what kind of like
what's-his-face that uh M night
Shyamalan ulema dingdong right he made
the Sixth Sense everybody went crazy and
then he made that movie where the guy
takes the nap and the lawnmower runs
over you know they can't all be gems
people look at ac/dc my favorite band of
all time they make like nine good
records in a row and then they made they
make does it blow up your video they had
that bad period fly-on-the-wall
who made who
blow up your video by better at it a bit
but edit it up
yeah they you know it is they got
outside their wheelhouse they were
actually trying to make a statement
where it's like no you guys are ac/dc
you talk about balls the devil and
[__] okay don't start making social
commentary about what's happening to the
art of music cuz it's gonna go off the
rails and that's exactly what happened
do I have do I actually have the nerve
to try to drag ac/dc into this this
tailspin of a podcast I apologize [__]
is wrong with me okay let's let's
recommend some YouTube videos for the
week
[Music]
videos all you got to see this one look
up 21-foot rule less talk more action
and it's basically it's a psycho who
he's basically saying he's talking to
gun people I guess this guy's a knife
sword guy and he's talking about the 21
foot rule that in the amount of time
it's gonna take you to pull out a gun
and I guessed or whatever and squeeze
off a shot he's gonna close the distance
and stab your cardboard tote torso so
check that out 21-foot rule and let's
talk more action and then there's a
couple of good parody ones there's the
hundred 21-foot rule where it's a fat
[__] doing the 21 foot rule 21-foot rule
from 121 feet and then there's the 21
foot rule light saber and by the way all
of these if you don't want to search for
these videos if you want them right at
your fingertips
if typing is too much of a bother cuz
you're too busy
all you have to do is go to the mm
podcast comm and all the videos will be
up there and right right all right at
the tip of your fingers you can select
them you can watch them and and that's
what you can do when I could actually
come up maybe with something else good
to say about the page if I wasn't so
[__] off this week I'm just off
people all right I'm [__] its we know it
bill we know it sucks okay we got it
alright here's another one to watch
watch one crazy Red Sox fan and it's
basically about a Red Sox fan who goes
to a Yankees game and start serving clam
chowder outside the stadium during a Red
Sox Yankees game but only two Red Sox
fans and if you if you just want to see
what you look like when you're drunk at
the game just watch this video because
it's pretty much equally embarrassing on
both sides the level of [__] morons
although I have to say a bunch of Boston
chicks show their tits on it
but then again that's because they're
happy women don't show their tits when
they're mad at you so I guess none of
the Yankee skanks showed their tits on
it but definitely definitely check that
[__] out but uh-oh is what I should have
talked about when I was talking about
the Celtics Lakers I was talking last
week about why do you why do we care so
much about sports you know why was I on
the plane flying across the country
absolutely livid that I wasn't gonna be
able to watch the game but part of me
was relieved that when I got off the
plane I was just gonna hear the results
and know one way or the other
you don't I mean just get [__] one
right to the back of the head rather
than sitting there slowly I don't know
slowly getting something something that
slowly [__] happens that's funny
right you know what [__] I'm about you
know what I am [__] if I [__] say
one more thing that's not funny on his
goddamn podcast I'm gonna [__] erase
it 25 minutes in which would be an
unprecedented move okay i bail out of
these things like a [__] test pilot
three minutes in five minutes in six
months even ten minutes in I've never
been less funny for [__] twenty five
minutes that I'm gonna scrap this
goddamn project this is pathetic this is
like that [__] plane that took off
like a helicopter and kept killing
people and was so [__] up even Dick
Cheney finally said you know what [__]
it it's not worth it but we spent four
billion dollars yeah but they keep
[__] going in the ground like a
goddamn lawn dart
that's what's happening this week
[__] sweat my ass off in my bedroom
yes I'm so I'm gonna blame and I blame
the climate alright I had a little
temper tantrum let's talk about sports
here why we care this is what you know I
was asking last week why do people give
a [__] about sports why do you care to
this level
why do you cheer on these guys half of
whom would blow you off if you saw him
you know might be seen it make me see
you know that [__] douchebag he
doesn't even smile during a game you
think he's gonna give you a [__]
autograph is he even in the league
anymore why don't you bring up fight a
blue bill there's a nice up-to-date
[__] reference
okay why we care this guy is a great
great theory thank God I'm gonna be
reading somebody else's words I hope he
has something funny to say all right
first off I want to say I love the
podcast not after this one sweetheart
you're doing God's work anyway I might
not be able to explain why all sports
fans care about their respective teams
but I thought I'd tell you why I care
and see if you or anyone else can relate
there are two main reasons why I not
only watch sports but actually allow
events that are usually happening
happening nowhere near me involving a
bunch of people I never have nor will I
ever meet affect my mood in either a
positive or a negative way first off is
the sheer unpredictability
unpredictability of it okay so so you
were surprised when you found out the
kid in sixth sense was already dead or
when Kevin Spacey started walking
straight in the end of you of the usual
suspects when neither of those were
worth a [__] compared to a guy catching
a pass with his helmet while being
dropped on his [__] head in the last
minute of a [__] Super Bowl to keep
the winning drive alive what a great
[__] point that is a great game in a
major sport football basketball baseball
and I'll even throw in hockey as a
courtesy to me oh thank you dude thank
you for uh thank you for actually
thinking about me um it's okay watching
a great game in either one of those
major sports is uh is for me better than
the best movie or TV show it's the
ultimate [__] drama and as far as I'm
concerned Oh as far as I'm concerned
second Jesus Christ I can't [__] read
the font is too short second following
teams and players over time you can see
some inspiring [__] I love how this guy
talks right when you think he's gonna be
intelligent he starts cursing this
sounds like my act you could see some
inspiring [__] this guy he's really a
motivational [__] [__] as a
Yankee fan I watched Derek Jeter go from
some skinny kid I'd never heard of to
arguably the greatest
shortstop of the modern era I watched
Andy Pettitte go from an okay rookie to
a [__] Jesus Freak who did steroids
sorry that was me um go from an okay
rookie to a guy who has an outside shot
at the Hall of Fame why because he
admitted that he [__] did I like how
he just came out and admitted that he
cheated and that makes it okay is that
all the bankers had to do yeah sorry we
actually took all the money and now old
people are eating dog food so they have
a chance of being in the Hall of Fame of
bankers is that what you're suggesting
sir
I really should stop heckling this
because I actually agree with what he's
saying here so now I have to go back
Tinie typing on a smaller scale I've
seen a guy like Phil Hughes go from
rookie a rookie who looked overrated a
couple years ago to a guy who's tearing
up the league right now
I'm sure for all the [__] Laker fans
seeing Pau Gasol finally step finally
step up and show some testicles instead
of allowing the cells to Punk them again
is inspiring on some level watching
players and teams overcome their
struggles make me think that if these
guys have it in themselves to go from
just believing they can achieve great
things to actually doing it I can too
maybe it sounds corny or like it came
out of a Disney movie but that's why I
give us [__] about sports you know and I
mean how can you argue that [__]
I mean how many times do you watch your
movie and within the first 10 minutes
you can figure out where it's going you
know there's the dude he's a [__]
loser there's the [__] cool guy he's
the [__] he's treating the guy like [__]
he's got the hot girlfriend the loser
guys actually ended why he need to
finish it G how's that one gonna end let
me guess the [__] good-looking girl
finally that realizes that her [__]
boyfriend who treats her like [__] from
the beginning of the movie is actually a
[__] boyfriend dumps him and then
she actually gets with this guy the
[__] loser how many times they make
that goddamn movie you know how many
[__] movies all of a sudden of the
you know vampires they just keep movies
making movies about vampires don't they
or TV shows where all of a sudden
vampires are sexy now is that what's
going on see that that was a bad example
I thought I'd got the podcast back on on
[__] track that was a terrible
example I went from being able to
predict how a movie's gonna go to
talking about trends and movies that
they're making a bunch of [__] vampire
movies what I should be saying is that
they're predictable actually they are
predictable all right some cool new kid
with a grey face is gonna move to school
and everyone's gonna look like say the
guy looks like he's [__] dead but
there's something about him that
everybody kind of likes and all the
girls [__] are gonna get wet because
there's something about his extra-long
[__] canines number six and number 11
- all you [__] dental douchebags out
there
you know then he [__] bites their
neck sucks their blood out then they
become [__] maniacs but it takes
three times and somehow that [__]
[__] you know is actually gonna have a
regular boyfriend but she can't resist
his gray face douche bag with the giant
[__] teeth she's gonna bang him one
other time she bangs one more time she's
gonna become a vampire and her boyfriend
who should just say [__] that [__] if
she wants to hang out with that big
tooth junkie [__] let her become a
vampire I don't give a [__] for some
reason he's so pussy-whipped he's got to
go save her and the only way to save her
is to drive a stake through that [__]
[__] heart and gee do you think he's
gonna do it do you think he's somehow
gonna save her in the end now can you do
that with sports what is predictable in
sports other than people are gonna get
absolutely [__] hammered and that
they're gonna be out of shape and that
they're gonna love that team when
they're good and they're gonna hate him
when they're bad but as far as the
outcome of the game you have no [__]
idea you know do you don't you think
right now is a Celtics fan that I want
to sit here and I want to start talking
[__] and say that it's a rap you know
what it's never a rap look at the Bruins
up three games to none against the
[__] Philadelphia Flyers go on and we
lose by the way congratulations to the
Chicago Blackhawks and my condolences to
the flier fans and I'm dead serious when
I said a lot of people think that I
[__] hate Philly because of that rant
when in reality I was you know just
doing a show and I was trying to piss
people off from Philly all right that
was a great thing to see but I got to
admit man that was the worst winning of
a championship I think I've ever seen
just for the just for those you who
don't watch hockey Patrick Kane in
overtime an overtime goal to win the
Stanley Cup he shoots the puck this is
really funny cuz people always hate
hockey ought to watch it on TV always
say they can't see the puck this [__]
guy shot the puck and it's somehow it
went in to the net heaters from from the
side he was almost parallel with the
goal with a goal line and he sure
and it disappeared into the side of the
net and no one could knew where the puck
was except for Patrick Kane who shot it
so he starts celebrating running down
with his hands in the air doing the jazz
hands you know and all his [__]
teammates are kind of like well
Patrick's freaking out dead silence in
the spectrum or wherever the [__] you
guys play the Wachovia Center dead
[__] silence and then they the reps
had to go and do a review of it and five
minutes later they like oh yeah yeah you
won the Stanley Cup and then they had to
regroup and get happy again I was such a
[__] buzzkill but congratulations to
the Blackhawks and hey Maple Leaf fans
let me ask you something will you
rooting for the Flyers I bet you were
because now you guys are the saddest
[__] sacks in the league isn't that
right oh wait is it 1967 is that the
last time you guys want it I believe it
is but if you want it the last time in
1967 than that and then you would
actually be tied with the expansion six
anybody in the expansion six who didn't
win it that would be the California
seals who I think went on to become the
Cleveland Barons but they folded so they
tapped out the st. Louis Blues have
never won it out of the expansion six
neither have the LA Kings Minnesota
North Stars one as the Dallas Stars in
one's wanted last year than one or two
times 91 and 92 look at this why do I
have this meaningless [__]
information in my head
flyers one at 7475
is that six right there one two three
four five six there you go
look this up Toronto when I stop and
just look this up God knows I'm not
being [__] funny this week
Toronto Maple Leafs that's actually a
city I want to do a [__] key stand up
key again but they never seem to [__]
pony up any goddamn money alright
the 1966 Stanley Cup final was the best
of seven series between the Montreal
Canadiens Toronto Maple Leafs Montreal
may believes win the Stanley Cup and
they'd never [__] win another one so
there you go so now it's a three-way
[__] tie for the longest futility in
hockey Toronto Maple Leafs the Los
Angeles Kings and whoever the [__] else
I said cuz I can't remember and the st.
Louis Blues and I'm praying all you guys
don't win because the next person on
that [__] list is then I believe
gonna be the Bruins in 1970 unless
Vancouver came in in like 70 is that
what happened Calgary Flames Capitals
they all came in the early 70s right
isn't this interesting I don't think it
is Jesus Christ let's go back let's go
let's let's go to some questions maybe
this will help me questions for the week
you know what I'm literally looking at
the clock this week the way I do when I
have a bad set and I'm looking down at
my watch like how many more minutes do I
have to do
how many more goddamn minutes alright
question bill if you had enough money to
quit stand-up and had the balls to give
up your dream of becoming ernest
borgnine where would you live
and what would you do with your time all
right
I have enough money and I can quit stand
up and I don't want to become an actor
all right uh where would I live and what
would I do with my time I would live
I think I'd live back east
and I would live on a big piece of land
where I could grow my own food I'd get a
pistol I get all the sports [__]
channels I think I would live in
I don't know I'd want to live right
outside of New York City one of those
places Tarrytown or and Jersey above
they've washed George Washington Bridge
all those [__] ritzy places but out
out in the sticks a little bit I'd live
there I'd enjoy the four seasons
they'd get a dog a couple of horses I
never ride I mean that's one of my goals
in life I want to get a couple of horses
and I want them never to be ridden in
their lives you know after I found out
what you have to do to make a [__]
horse want to be ridden you got to break
them
the same way they break those [__]
those people who work at hardware stores
and slash terrorists down in Guantanamo
Bay you know you got to do that to a
[__] horse and even then the horse
she never quite cuz I I noticed a couple
the one or two times I've ridden a horse
they still kind of are rebellious they
do [__] like a friend of mine actually
used to work with horses and said when
you go to put the saddle on them you got
a tug it reeled you got a tug the belt
underneath you got a tug it real tight
cuz what they'll do is they'll take a
big inhale all right and then when you
go to gang and you tie it on and then
when you go to get on top of it they
exhale and the saddle slides down you
fall off the [__] horse I mean right
if I if I ever had a horse and it ever
did that [__] right there I would look
into its big brown beautiful horse eyes
and I would be like you you don't want
to be ridden do you you know well then
that's it it's [__] over
it's [__] over I'm not riding you
anymore all right
good go run around in this fenced in
area and don't [__] complain I'm
fenced in to this areas I can't go to I
can't just cross borders the other thing
I [__] up that is with like countries
and that type of [__] I'll just way
you're born you're just all of a sudden
on that team you know like why we're not
allowed to just wander you know why
can't I just
walk to Brazil
like the old days
[__] go in and wash some dishes at a
saloon make a little bit of money and
then jump on a [__] stagecoach and
ride out of town or some [__] right
just [__] head down to Brazil and
chill out down he can't [__] do it
anymore
gotta have all these goddamn
identifications microchips and all this
[__] I got to worry about roving bands a
[__] gorilla Terrace
arrested abroad you guys ever see that
[__] show arrested abroad makes you
like you never want to travel again I
have to tell you even even this last
time when I went it when I went out of
the country and I went to England
Ireland in Scotland not only
ridiculously white not only do they all
speak English but I'm actually have
ancestry in all those parts of the
country I still couldn't quite relax
until I got back on my own turf you know
I saw a spiral I saw somebody with dirty
toes and flip-flops I was like America
I'm back I'm [__] back
can you do that and no you can't even
even in like like how does it work over
in Europe when you you know those dirty
American college kids all of a sudden
decide to get on a [__] that kind
they become dirty because I want to do
it that you get on a train just go
around Europe
how does that work do you have to show
your passport you'll papers please do
you have to do that or are you guys so
advanced in the New World Order that
you're all in the same [__] currency
and you just have one DMV making you a
[__] driver's license with a barcode
in the back have you seen that you guys
seen that new creepy commercial
wait wait I didn't know what the [__]
going on they have a baby in the middle
it and they have all these this
electronic [__] like examining every
inch of the beta that IBM commercial the
way they're selling microchipping the
entire world with become a smarter
planet
becoming smarter plant it right who's
gonna argue with that no one wants to
know wants to become a dumber planet
watch those commercials and read between
the lines and see what the [__] they're
setting you up for they're already
getting you comfortable with all these
this this robotic laser [__] looking at
your naked little baby they got a
[__] just like a goddamn dog they
gonna stick a microchip right in the
back a [__] barcode right on that soft
part of his [__] eye that's where they
gonna stay this third eye soft part of
his skull that's where they're gonna
bury the microchip right I give it one
more generation and the only job that
there's gonna be as a [__] human
being other than wiping the ass of the
Illuminati is to be the guy who owns the
[__] robots other than that the rest
of us were going down we're all getting
processed that's my message on this
happy [__] horrific car crash of a
[__] podcast next question so that's
what I do I would live back east and I
would like to live on a big piece of
property and I'd like to learn how to
grow my own food even if I wasn't into
that conspiracy theory type of [__] I
just there's just something about it I I
think you you should know how to live
off the land I think you should know how
to survive in the wild I just think that
stuff
I think should know how to defend
yourself all of this stuff I don't know
how to do you know you know I know how
to defend myself as you put me in a
headlock I put you in a headlock and
then we both [__] there tugging on each
other going quit it you quit you quit
first like that's all I know how to do
you know sit on your chest and [__]
punch you that's I know how to do that I
if you're my little brother I know how
to beat you up I don't know how to
survive in the wild I was actually on
the the internet the other day and I was
trying to learn how to hotwire a car and
pick a lock just in case just in case
this [__] happens and I'm that guy
running around with cargo pants and a
backpack like that [__] show they
have you seen that show after the
apocalypse the guy goes through the
garbage and he somehow finds
you know stuff to eat how to start a
fire I know how to do any that [__] I
want to learn how to do that [__] so I
don't take the coward way out and just
kill myself you know a lot of people
have that as a plan that's it back up
well [__] goes down I'll just kill
myself you know next next problem all
right your next question here we go dear
bill I'm 19 and I do stand-up in New
York City well at least I did until I
ran out of money paying for all the open
mics and transportation I'm trying
show him yawning here I'm trying to get
a job to pay for what I love doing
sounds like a plan right absolutely it
sounds like a plan but of course this
[__] will eventually hit the fan in
about a month and a half my mom is going
to move back to New England and I'm
definitely not going back because one
that [__] sucks and two New York is the
best place to do stand-up every day my
mom and my older brother give me [__]
for every little thing every day
my what sorry my [__] I just jumped
the line I'm trying to get a job but I
look like a hippie so that [__] ain't
easy so every day my mom and older
brother give me [__] for everything
thing I do I'm trying to get a job but I
look like a hippie so that [__] ain't
easy now for the part that leaves me
make making leaves me looking like a
[__] I feel like no matter what I do
I'm wasting time I should do stand-up
every night and my carefree attitudes
does nothing but piss off these
stressed-out bastards in my house if you
were in this situation what would you do
well you didn't give me enough of your
situation to fully tell you I don't know
how old you are
Oh 19 you're 19
what do I do I would get a [__] job
that's what I would do I would get a job
that would allow me to stay in the
tri-state area I would continue to do
stand-up down there that's what I would
do if you don't want to move to Boston
but you know if you wanted to move to
Boston I mean that's where I started I
can't really comment on the scene the
scene was great when when I was up there
and I had a day job and I did spots at
night came to work sleepy or whatever
and I got myself to the point I just
saved up a ton of money I can give you
this advice whatever you do don't get a
[__] credit card and get yourself
into some ridiculous debt because that
is the that's the modern-day slavery is
the loaning of money at interest and you
need to avoid that at all [__] costs
so what I would do get a reliable car
all this [__] requires money but I would
not go out and buy a brand-new [__]
car get a job and get all this [__]
debt to quote-unquote build up your
credit I wouldn't do any of that [__]
all right I would keep myself I wouldn't
be in a relationship you know I wouldn't
I wouldn't I would keep it I keep it
real light travel light is what I would
say travel like dude you 19 years old
you ought to be able to sleep on the
sidewalk all right your body is still
brand new its brand [__] new you
don't have any aches or pains
do you want to stay there you just stay
there find a [__] job whatever you
got to do just get a goddamn job out
there and then I would continue on and
then just think positive think positive
and as bad and no matter how bad it
[__] gets just think this is just a
funny chapter in a bit up in a book then
I'll write someday or a funny story to
tell if I'm sitting on the couch on
Conan one day just look at it that way
don't listen to the negative [__]
around you and just keep going that's
what I would do if you want to stay in
the New York area and do stand-up and
that's exactly what the [__] I would do
do that that is my advice to you good
luck to you sir and I hope it all works
out for you
and if by the time you make it I've
already made it and then have a [__]
brutal drug habit help me out toss me
toss me an opening gig I'll open for you
all right this is one of the last things
there's gonna be a short podcast this
week I apologize I just no [__] to
have it this week I really don't I got a
million things on my [__] mind I got
a bunch of bills I have to pay I got all
this [__] I'm running around hey you
know it's [__] up day I got by I
thought I was gonna be doing Letterman
again next week I got bumped again I got
bumped again so at least that's stress
he's taken off it's kind of cool though
because the set has been ready since May
so rather than the panic that I usually
have usually when they asked me to do
Letterman they call me up they go what
do you got you got five minutes ready
and as always I lie and I go yeah I got
five minutes clean material and then I
frantically try to put it together and
you know I stressful like [__] 14
days before I finally start to get it I
feel like I have it and then it always
ends up going well but there's an
unbelievable amount of stress but the
thing is I already went through that
[__] in April getting ready for the
beginning of May and then you know then
it went away and then it started to
build up again and all of a sudden June
I'm ready to go and then today boom
you're out you [__] out so so I'm
ready
I don't what the point of that [__]
story was you know what I just am I
allowed to take a week off people am i
how about this we just we just got the
final copy of my new special is ready we
just locked the master or whatever they
say technically it's ready to go
I got extras and one of the extras
actually is the Monday morning podcast
which would have been a great thing to
bring up if if this was actually a
decent podcast but one of the extras is
we I filmed one of my podcasts another
extras is some people heckling me in a
club couple episodes of that and
whatever the rest of it you'll find out
when you buy the thing and considering
this thing is free I'm letting you guys
know right now when I get an actual
release date for this for the podcast
I'm gonna be coming at you guys hard and
heavy with the guilt okay and if you
think you're only gonna be required to
buy one DVD I got news for you I got I'm
going more than that alright I'm not
gonna say how many I think you should
buy but it's more than one and it's less
than three but I'm not gonna say with
that number with you all right let's
delete the last thing here overrated for
this week overrated sprint customer
service I swear to god these people are
just there to piss you off bill it's
like no matter what you say they have
some textbook comeback to make you seem
like an [__] how funny is that what
do they explain the phone you don't get
it so now you blaming them I actually
know what you're saying I have been with
Sprint for years now and I'm always
bitching to them about their shitty
phones but I kick butt can you blame me
either the screen either the screen
breaks or the [__] thing doesn't
charge like two days ago I went in yet
again to get my phone looked at because
when I plugged in the charger the phone
wouldn't charge so I bring the phone up
and the charger I bring the phone and
the charger up into the store and the
douchebag behind the counter says the
charger port in the phone is bad we will
order you a new phone come back in two
days and it'll be here it'll be here for
you
keep in mind they looked at both the
phone and the charger so I say that's
fine with me
ordering a phone takes some time two
days no no big deal
two days later I pick up the phone and
bring it home to find out the [__]
thing doesn't charge so I'm sitting here
thinking what the [__] did they order me
and what the what the [__] did they
order me a new phone for so I go back to
the Sprint store and I very calmly
explained that the charger was the
problem the whole time like I had said
since the beginning so they go back and
[__] around with the things some more
and this [__] comes back to me and tells
me that I was right and here's where I
get pissed she tells me that I need to
buy the new charger myself because
apparently full insurance doesn't cover
accessories I swear to god I never would
never hit a woman but this [__] got me
so angry I explained that that they were
the one they were the ones who diagnose
diagnose the [__] problem not me they
are the ones who ordered a new phone
when I didn't even need one plus I had
away two days to find out all this to
find all that [__] out and they still
charge me $40 for the [__] thing
no discount or anything sorry just had
to vent yeah that's one of those deals
where you have to you have to stop
talking to the person at the counter
first thing you have to do is you got to
keep your temper in check I did a whole
segment on this about a year ago about
the magic of the word unacceptable and
whatever wisdom I learned was fleeting
because I've gone right back to flipping
out and screaming at people and I can
tell you from personal experience it
that that is not it's not does not get
you to the desired results so what you
should have done was say that I need to
talk to somebody above you I understand
you don't make these rules you just keep
complimenting the person and you just
keep saying it's unacceptable
unacceptable eventually that you're
gonna get to the highest person in the
store and what they're gonna do is tell
you that you then have to jump through a
couple [__] hoops email people
something involving the internet and
they're all just hoping you're gonna tap
out but if you never [__] tap out
you're gonna get what you
have coming to you that's just what they
do that's just how it works now and you
know I don't know what to tell you I
don't know what to tell you I don't even
know what to say God knows it won't be
anything funny this [__] piece of
[__] of a [__] podcast this [__]
podcast what was it was was a car here's
some questions for you this week if this
podcast was a car what would it be if it
was a comedian who would it be if it was
a president who would it be
go to the mmm podcast people the mmm
podcast.com go to that page we'll have
the questions up there and you can
[__] send in your answers and I'll
read them next week if you want to trash
me go right ahead I [__] deserve it
then you know what this is this is the
first time a podcast has really seemed
like work usually I'm in here I'm having
a good time maybe I'm [__] jet-lagged
what if I just ran out of funny you know
they always say that do you got to worry
about that [__] as a comedian you just
dry up
maybe I'm drying up I turned 42 years
old and that's it that was the magic
number first 18 years of his career man
today the guy [__] just steadily
improved he just kept getting better and
better and better and then he hit 42 and
I don't know what happened
he started regressing first thing he did
he started doing the podcast in the
afternoon when it was hot he started
sweating cooking his [__] brain you
know just [__] all went downhill from
this he write that I was gonna go on
some sort of a riff and it just [__]
ended I got nothing why would I think
after 55 minutes of mental torture dead
all of a sudden I was just gonna pull
this [__] jam out of my ass is that
what I thought was going to happen it
didn't
I got [__] news for you it didn't my
brain would just started thinking of the
oil spill like I was gonna riff on that
I got nothing to say about it cuz I'm
[__] watched a second of it cuz
there's nothing I can do about it
alright put a picture up when when you
clogged the [__] hole by the way they
ever gonna be able to clean that up are
we so in trouble that they do you
realize that they actually listened to
Kevin Costner Kevin Costner actually got
a meeting with the government that's how
dumb I am I don't even know what branch
of the government he went to Washington
and he met with the government you know
whatever the [__] he did he went to one
of those buildings that's painted white
and has pillars out in the front and he
went in there and there was [__] five
old people sitting there in suits and he
you know he did the usual I didn't come
here as an actor I came here as a blah
Blee he's got some side company that I
guess vacuums oil off the top of the
water how did it even get that meeting
what are they well he was in Waterworld
his water right there [__]
but the Fabi he and he did [__] play
uh John F Kennedy actually no sir he
didn't he played the guy investigating
it while he was in contact with the
president there you go right there
he fought in the Civil War he [__]
played baseball he built the goddamn
Stadium what more does this guy have to
[__] do to get a goddamn meeting with
us he fingered bag meg Ryan in the back
of that limo
what else did he do I can't I can't
remember any of his fine oh I'm [__]
all he's up he was [__] with the guy
from The Breakfast Club when they went
skydiving Fandango
hey remember that one kid who had that
part in the movie and Fandango who just
slept in the back of the car the entire
[__] movie I had my part in date
night was one level above that that
actor and Fandango called me and the guy
from weekend at bernie's called me to
see how did you get eight lines
dude you're blowing up you [__]
blowing up
so anyways [__] Kevin Costner who
like Jack Nicholson is gonna take
forever to go bald you know I don't know
what those guys dumped on their [__]
heads but they they really they stave it
off they really stave it off I on the
other hand I'm not using any of that
[__] I'm just letting it [__] happen
and then what I'm gonna do is in ten
years I figured the fact that they they
can grow a [__] colon
outside of the human body if they can
[__] do that in int any and then and
then take out the old one and stick the
new one in like you just got a new
exhaust system there's no [__] way
they're not gonna have a cure for this
[__] in ten [__] years
pop a pill and she'll just start growing
back like magic like [__] magic I
learned that it learned that the other
day when I was watching one of those
shows for you know it's not uh it's not
out to pay it's your actual [__] hair
right and they got that fifty year old
guy running his hands through his his
Jay Leno head of hair now and he's going
you know I wish I did this ten years ago
and it's like dude no you know you don't
know you don't if you go back and look
at what hair plugs look like ten years
ago sir you're gonna say I'm really glad
I waited it's like people are going to
get their tattoos removed and then they
just have that permanent Indian sunburn
cuz they [__] it up because it's new
just wait a few years wait a few years
it's all gonna be great that's that's my
advice for you if you can wait I had a
buddy of mine who did crystal meth and a
bunch of [__] up drugs and he dried
out his joints and had to get like hip
replacement surgery at like 36 and he's
needed it for like six years and the
doctor says just wait just wait just
wait
cuz when I was younger if you got hip
replacement surgery you were [__]
unless you got it at like 60 or 70 cuz
it only lasted for like ten years and
people used to die in their sixties John
Wayne all of them [__] rump roasts
hanging out of the [__] your anus he
just collapsed one day
[__] it was just rump roast and Geritol
pills under undigested Geritol pills
that's that's all you just die to that
and everybody dropped in their [__]
sixties but whatever what I'm trying to
say is you [__] you hip only lasted
for 10 years and then then you were in a
wheelchair like what's-his-face Earl
Campbell or old Campbell now was in a
wheelchair but my buddy has NIT needed
it for like five six seven years and uh
five six seven years ago the doctor said
of stuttering again said that he needed
this hip replacement surgery and he's
just told him if he can wait if he could
deal with the pain that the advancements
that they were having he would be so
much better and he waited and hadn't
seen the guy in a minute one of those
friends we showed up you only went to a
[__] hockey game or something and he
had handicapped plates and I couldn't
understand why and he's walking normally
said oh I had I had hip replacement
surgery and I was like when he said like
six months ago and he's [__] walking
around all normal I get the [__] out of
here goes yeah and he explained the
whole thing how now they used to like
just cut your whole leg open almost from
like hip down to your knee and just
remove your entire hip and like I don't
know like the like half your [__]
femur now I don't know what they do I
don't know what they do but it's working
people is this interesting me explaining
[__] hip surgery I don't even know
what I'm talking about maybe that will
work with the oil spill you what the big
deal is is I like how Kevin Costner has
actually has a side business that's so
[__] smart cuz if you listen to this
[__] podcast shouldn't I really have
a side business shouldn't I have
something to fall back on
yeah [__] that's it alright go [__]
yourselves I'm sorry
have a good week don't judge me I'll be
back next week
okay Eminem had a couple of bad albums I
heard his new ones [__] unbelievable
alright
[Music]